Chris Brown album comes out
and then out of nowhere this God did
record which is one of the we talked
about this a bit on uh at the BT uh
radio room but like obviously man this
God did [__] is like one of the craziest
Jay-Z verses we've ever gotten
um I mean from performing he had the BET
Awards uh uh I mean just they're just or
the Grammy [__] see look he said get it
right it was the Graham sure
um such an insane moment in hip-hop I
mean got Cal I feel like that record
really kind of
really set Khaled up to to you know be
looked at in a different way
um in terms of like putting records
together but give me the back story of
like
I guess the whole process of that song
because we've seen the video of you
singing it yeah was that in your bedroom
yeah and that was that did you did you
record that prior
like like while you're actually cutting
that hook yeah I made it and you're like
I recorded a while I'm in it that's just
crazy I knew it was going to be special
yeah like
I would tell you the story like I told
you I was writing for a little bit so I
was in this Pub deal in the a r left
and it was on some [__] like I ain't
have nobody else like I'm broke as [__]
I had no connection into the building
besides that a r
so me and my team was looking for a like
a buyout somebody else would buy my
manager Edgar to buy out your buy me on
my Pub dude yeah so my manager Edgar he
he connected to uh Eddie Mary J Blige
manager he worked at another Pub company
prescription he telling him like bro we
need to be looking for a buyout we need
this bio like he the one I'm telling you
yeah like he was just pushing it and
then
money go by they finally buy me out my
Pub do so we fresh into this Pub dude
Chris Brown come up
and then I'm watching Khaled on
Instagram say God did every day like
every time I wake up I think he said God
did like every day for like three months
yep I've been had like a goddess sample
and then I called my manager I got my
bro let's send it let's send it to
College simple he like nah I make a hook
like a real hook like just you type [__]
I made the hook bro as soon as I started
like the idea I called my camera man but
I said come to the crib this is special
special bro like I already had the
melody like before I recorded it I
already had like the the melody not even
the words I just knew where I was gonna
take it
as soon as I made it bro I knew that
[__] was the one now did you get the
pretty immediate feedback from Cali that
like oh this is something like this is
but I know you didn't know who didn't
make you didn't know who who actually
made it on the record for a while right
so look after I made it right we call
Eddie
we played it for Eddie
that [__] went crazy he had Kylie
number texted to call it
Cali takes back like the next day
I need this on my other
you know what I'm saying like a week go
by we already starting the paperwork at
first it was supposed to be like a like
a
interlude just me with the keys how you
hear my hook a couple days go by he like
I just put three artists on here and a
singer
so this [__] gonna live forever as soon
as he said that bro I'm already thinking
like Nas Kanye Jay-Z I'm thinking oh
high level names based off the like the
record yeah for sure
so I I I I heard rumors of who was on
the track but I I didn't hear the track
till it came up bro like everybody else
so when you heard Jay-Z had like a
[__] I don't know how many minutes
what was it five minute long version
five minute long worth made it
impossible to play a radio I'll tell you
that
they was trying to make all kind of
random versions of that song when they
were working at the radio I'm like guys
it's just too long guys this is not
seven minute song is not working the
radio God bless it it's a great record
but
um what was your reaction here in Hope
go off nah it was crazy bro
guest Jay-Z for top three guess JC first
ever she's gonna live forever bro just
normal part of that it's a blessing bro
were you nervous doing the Grammy
performance outside with everybody like
yeah I was nervous as [__] like no as
soon as they told me I was performing I
was I was bitching bro like the whole
it's like a month before they told me I
was performing I'm like [__] bro like
I didn't expect this this early bro like
do you like do you like really like
train like a fighter trains training
your voice making sure you hit [__]
yeah I'm saying like the week of the
Grammys bro every day I was singing yeah
I did like all day
just so it's like by the time the
Grammys come I can't mess up because
I've been singing it all week when I
woke up showers singing that [__] I
remember like right before he was about
to perform
Cali came to my um
where I was getting dressed that type
[__] it's on my tick tock and he played
the instrumental in my ear
his whole team everybody that was Jay-Z
everybody outside
he put the joint in my ear I even know
he thought I was gonna sing that was
before the performance and I just
started singing it and everybody like he
ready and I just once that happened bro
I just went on stage with that same
energy bro knocked it out the park man
yeah
um talk about like some of your
influences growing up obviously uh being
out of Philly man Philly's obviously a
legendary hip-hop City there's so many
different
artists we can go back to the roots uh
obviously all the way to Meek Mill and
you know the freeway all that good [__]
but like who were you influenced by
growing up uh I grew up in a church so
it was just like soulful music when I
was a kid and then like when I outside
of it I'll start going to like Boys to
Men
you know what I'm saying like what was
that dude with that deep voice on Boys
to Men deep as [__] I know you talking
about he would talk and [__] yeah
yeah
I forgot his name though but that was
like I hope he's on Cameo that'd be the
Cameo to get like just have him lay down
your voice like your voicemail like hey
what up ladies you called Friday leave a
voicemail and yes this is me from Boys
to Men
yeah that was like my my like first an
inspiration obviously Philly Legends
yeah so it's like
and then it was like right after they
was just like all r b like Jamie Foxx
Brian McKnight then I started like
living my life in like Meek Mill Kanye
West and Drake shots of I mean Jamie
Foxx alien level Talent yeah different
[__] don't know like they sleep on his
music that first album that I'm the
unpredictable oh my God yeah that uh
what was that song called one night okay
it was a one night occasion
that [__] that [__] man I was I'm so
glad he's all right yeah for sure he's
one of the ones top tier actor top tier
comedian top tier singer singer just
everything he's a beast man yeah and
shout out to uh shout out to his new
movie uh the Clone Tyrone yeah right now
yeah it's going crazy so obviously you
you uh you end up
for you the Catalyst to start writing
and like I guess everyone kind of you
said you had a pub deal that you had to
get bought out of right so what was like
your first initial like real step into
being in the quote-unquote music
industry like how did you get that
initial Pub deal like before we really
knew who you were you know what I'm
saying uh
[__] I uh
around like it was like 2019 2020.
that's when I met uh my manager okay and
remember he was like bro start writing
yes so when I met him I was like making
like 10 hooks a week bro like were you
still in Philly yeah I was in my the
same room just in the crib at the crib
make sure you're like cutting the hook
sending them to him and then yeah he's
doing his job he's sending it out yeah
so it's like I was made like 10 10 songs
a week
yeah at that time I was close to my man
produced my producer the new the new zo
and I started making a lot of Beats on
his a lot of hooks on his a lot of hooks
on his Beach yeah and he was about to
get signed um
the person he was about to sign to
they're like who they on the hooks
like you know what I'm saying he hard so
that's how like
that's how that happened with my first
Pub dealership and now when they ask
who's that on the hook they keep you on
the hook yeah they keep they keep me now
now they're like oh that's the yeah it's
Friday sure yeah we're gonna need that
come over here